émission de foot ce soir il y aura du
beau gosse il y aura des femmes
il y aura des femmes mi figue mi raisin
mais je ne peux pas leur garde
non mais jean michel mr nos problèmes
le problème selon michel oui c'est
yoplait le problème jean michel seydoux
crédible non mais c'est en colère on
dirait didier bourdon dans le sketch
télématique vraiment heureux dit
franchement on dirait un golf que
j'aurais plus dragué quoi mais vous je
n'ai pas et l'on porte on vous fait une
imitation c'est sylvie vartan vous
pouvez nous la faire oui bien sûr
la mousse est comme si d'accord c'est
entre sylvie vartan edouard balladur
voilà on aime bien préparé chacun notre
imitation fétiche
on aime bien aussi gilbert d' allah
[Applaudissements]
alors je lance tout de suite hashtag
gras sera style angoisse tout de suite
parce que il est vraiment angoissant
quoi rien dit hannon mais est ce que on
fait comme si je rentrais dans un bar
s'il vous plaît bonsoir beau gosse
[Applaudissements]
zion ou tout seul oui mon enfant oui
blanche neige moi non moi je suis je
suis venue seule mais je vais repartir
ça je pense qu'on va voir mon chéri
voulait voir quelque chose
volontiers de coupe monsieur généreuse m
[Rires]
la maison la maison brick lane
c'est quoi votre meilleure imitation
vous l'aimez de leurs dents mais chemin
merci cd et dalida en tout cas mais
savez vous êtes à mes bras quand vous
vous trouvez flippant parce que ça a été
très très bien fait assez crédible et
vous vous à côté vraiment isabelle on
dirait que vous êtes la patronne
[Applaudissements]
on dirait la patronne du bar jean ah
ouais 28e puis tu redescends parce que
yaya diallo bah affaire est ma meilleure
imitation moi je vais vraiment faire
dalida j'ai mis dos bien oui voilà voulu
je suis vachement bien mais d'où
attendait chellouche d'arnave 2000
milieu rural est un atout
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi votre meilleure
imitation je suis nul en imitant sur les
i vous allez me nul nul nul
bon je vais faire renault sinon vous
avez des gens un peu mal acquis voilà il
ya déjà des voix laissant la génération
réalésé oui j'étais tranquille c'est bon
on a compris que je retiens me remercie
et pour les imitations je sais faire que
homer simpson ou pinaise c'est bien vous
eric un fait quoi comme une mutation est
encore trop s'en fout je sais faire
ouais non un peu de tout ça la magie non
mais c'est bon